hey 42 here did you know the final book
in the series harry potter and the
deathly hallows
holds the world record for the most
copies sold the day of release
on the 21st of july 2007 roughly 11
million books flew off the shelves
in just 24 hours and into the hands of
young wannabe witches and wizards
but as soon as jk rowling had finished
writing the last installment of the
series that's earned her
hundreds of millions even a billion by
some estimates
she started on another book the potter
nerds amongst you will know that in
deathly hallows
hermione is given a collection of
popular wizarding fairy tales titled
the tales of beadle labard as a thank
you to the key people that had made the
harry potter series a reality
rowling decided to produce six copies of
the tales of beadle lobard
all handwritten and illustrated by her
and set with silver ornaments
and semi-precious stones a priceless way
to say
thank you you might think well
actually we can put a price on them
because rowling then changed her mind
opting to create
a seventh copy set with a moonstone to
be sold at auction
the auction was to raise money for the
children's charity she'd founded
and it took place on december the 13th
at sotheby's auction house in london it
was expected to sell for around 50 000
pounds
and it's fair to say it surpassed
expectations
eventually being bought by amazon for
1.95
million pounds but even possum mania
couldn't propel the exclusive copy
up into the echelons of the most
expensive books
of all time near the top of the pile
just below william shakespeare's first
folio
and leonardo da vinci's scientific
journal
lies the gutenberg bible
a copy of which sold for nearly 8
million pounds in today's money
back in 1978. the bible is considered
the best selling book of all time with
guinness world records estimating
in 1995 that over 5
billion copies had been sold worldwide
i mean it was all right i'll admit the
first part was quite gripping
i liked the plagues and mass genocide
but it all got a bit preachy in the
second half
so anyway why is gutenberg's copy
so expensive the gutenberg bible was
one of if not the first book ever
printed on mars
which is a rather easy accolade to snap
up
when you've only gone and bloody
invented the first ever printing press
when goldsmith johannes gutenberg's
printing press hit the streets of
strasbourg in 1440
where he was under political exile he of
course had
the novel issue of needing to create the
world's first
font gutenberg used movable type to
print books
at far larger volumes than was
previously possible
with the gutenberg bible being the first
to roll off the press
reading started to shift from an
exclusive pastime
of the elite to one more universally
accessible
of course every stinking peasant
being able to read his own copy of the
bible
was the tinderbox for the protestant
reformation
a handful of decades later gutenberg's
text dora sometimes called black letter
can be considered the world's first
font and it was created to imitate a
fairly
intricate handwritten style in use since
1150.
the scarcity of intact and complete
copies of gutenberg's bible
600 years on has led to an exorbitant
price tag
whilst gutenberg painstakingly created
his
font by hand these days anyone can make
their own font
and there are more than half a million
available worldwide
today we're spoilt for choice you can
spend a good couple of hours choosing
the perfect font from
thousands for the front of your
congratulations on fornicating
i mean having a baby card choosing a
fund was previously
the domain of typesetters but that all
changed in 1984.
i'll admit our protagonist here is not
the sort you'd expect to revolutionize
the way we
write he was a smoking college dropout
who taken a few calligraphy classes
after flunking his normal ones
but when he developed his initial model
in a long line of computers
that were the first to offer their users
a choice of typefaces
he loaded it with some new fonts named
after cities he loved
toronto san francisco london
and geneva amongst others one in
particular
would become very well known
chicago was defunct not just for the
computer menus
but those of the hugely successful
portable music players
that followed that student dropout was
none other than polo neck enthusiast
steve jobs and that computer
was the very first mac and that music
player
was the ipod whilst it was these devices
that made him
rich and famous his biggest contribution
to mankind
well probably one of them was giving us
the ability to print out
whatever we desired in any chosen font
be honest we've all printed something in
a horrific
font perhaps it was your list of social
mores for your bedroom door
including classics such as no girls
allowed
knock before entering and piss off mum
i've already got a dad and he's not
called roberto
indeed abusing your family's first
printer with abhorrent typography
is basically a 21st century rite of
passage
thankfully after that period of
childhood experimentation
most of us develop a slightly better eye
for what works
and what induces ocular bleeding and
indeed certain fonts have surfaced as
typographic a-listers cooper black
is friendly and unthreatening one might
even call its letters pudgy
whilst it enjoyed success in various
uses like the credits of british tv
series dad's army
the beach boys album pet sounds and of
course
as the iconic font of choice for budget
so long as you haven't packed your
grandma
airline easyjet its use
is even mandated in the company's
mission statement
but easyjet was only founded in 1995
and cooper black was designed in the
1920s
so what attracted ol stelios to it
oswald bruce cooper designed cooper
black
having been commissioned by barnhart
brothers and spindler
a type foundry looking for a new
typeface to entice advertisers
it's a serif font that doesn't look like
one
it's weight which in typography land
means
thickness might otherwise be imposing
but somehow appears friendly
its large letters are close in size to
their upper case equivalents
the rounded serifs are easy to see even
from a distance
and the small counters the enclosed
spaces in letters like
o p and a give it an almost
chubby look it's a font which looks best
from a distance
and so slapping it on the side of a
massive passenger jet
is an obvious application albertus is
another font where bigger
is better but this time not for its
chunkiness
it conveys a traditional roman style
with a touch more flare
than most and so it's no surprise that
it adorns countless classy nameplates
in the financial district of london
albertus was created by bertholf
walp a jewish german calligrapher who
fled the nazis to england in 1935.
that's the problem when you're a racist
megalomaniac
you end up scaring away your best talent
handing the enemy advantages like
pretty typography and you know atomic
bombs
walp joins the famous publishing house
faber and faber
to work on book jackets featuring both
established and up-and-coming authors
like t.s eliot seamus heaney and william
golding
albertus was a font he'd built from
scratch drawing on his training in a
bronze foundry
where he'd carved raised inscriptions on
memorial tablets
it was his process of physically cutting
away the metal from around the letters
that led him to develop such a sharp
bold font that was easy to read
even from a distance and with details
which looked fantastic at larger sizes
like the sharp point in the center of
its capital b
if it looks familiar but you don't ever
recall
seeing its large letters emblazoned
across a financial firm's
high-rise building imagine for a second
standing on the edge of that skyscraper
would you experience a rush of blood to
the head
or wish you had parachutes
with you that's right albertus was also
coincidentally
the font of choice for the covers of
coldplay's
first free albums albertus is an older
farm that still sees use today
but when things are the other way around
trouble can arise new fonts in places
they
shouldn't be are a pet peeve of those in
the industry
especially when it comes to films
used well fonts can add realism to
scenes set in the past
but type designer mark simonson
whose popular font proxima nova which is
used by
sites like buzzfeed mashable and wired
has a section of his website dedicated
to the use
and misuse of certain fonts
in movies even well-loved and celebrated
films like chocolate
which garnered five academy award
nominations
aren't spared set in rural 1950s france
it's hard to believe that the town's
mayor could have produced a notice
that uses itc benguat a typeface
created in 1978.
whilst these details may sound minor the
few
fun-loving type experts amongst us will
nevertheless appreciate the effort
that's gone into films that do get it
right
oh and if you're sitting there wondering
what's the damned difference between a
typeface and the font anyway
a typeface refers to a font family like
helvetica
whereas a font is a specific style of
that family
such as helvetica bold or helvetica
light
i'd wager that nowadays more people than
ever before
will recognize the fonts used in films
people are becoming more aware of the
fonts they use
because well computers
having a favorite font is no longer the
preserve of typographers
it's become another way we can express
ourselves
as a cambrian man or a johnston-sans
gal the latter being the corporate font
commissioned
and used by london public transport
since 1913 and a particular favorite of
mine
which i suppose makes me a johnston-sans
gal
most of us don't realise we care about
fonts until
we suddenly do this was the case
in late 2009 after ikea
swapped all its in-store signage from
the slim
and elegant futora to the modern
vedana the reason for the switch was
consistency
ikea already used verdana on its website
the font was everywhere thanks to its
adoption by google
and microsoft and they've only gone and
switched it yet again in 2019
to google's noto typeface futora on the
other hand
is considered quirky and timeless
despite being heralded as
the typeface of our time way back in
1920s germany
it still has a modern innovative feel to
it
and is perhaps why it adorns not only
volkswagen adverts
but also the inscribed plaque which the
apollo 11 astronauts
left on the moon whilst the lunar plaque
is expected
to stand the test of time the same
cannot be said for
what many consider to be the most
beautiful
font ever made the doves press was
founded in the late 19th century
by tj cobden sanderson and emery walker
and named after a nearby riverside pub
in hammersmith
dove's press created what many consider
one of the most
beautiful fonts known as dove's roman
or simply doves the dove's bible of 1902
is regarded as a masterpiece proudly
displaying a g
with a dynamic tilted bowl and a sharp
definite y whose tail is a straight
slash
sadly we can no longer enjoy doves in
its original glory
after a dispute between cobb and
sanderson
and walker saw much of the fund
lost forever upon dissolving their
partnership
a long and bitter legal dispute
eventually saw
copton sanderson come away with the
rights to doves
but only until his death
after which walker would receive them
cobden sanderson then reneged on the
agreement
worried by the thoughts that his
beautiful font would be used to print
cheap publications or crude material
he spent three years slowly dumping the
font
from the heavy casts for the physical
letters
to the solid metal pages that had been
used on their final book
into the thames he take the blocks
wrapped them in paper and then carried
them down the road
often walking half a mile or more to
find the best spot
there he'd wait for heavy traffic so
that no one could hear the splash they'd
make
he wrote of his fear that the police the
public
even the newspapers would catch him in
the act the process took
captain sanderson then in his 70s
some six months and 170 trips
but eventually doves was no more
his crimes against a typographic world
were only discovered
after his death detailed as they were in
his will and his diary
incensed walker promptly opened legal
proceedings
against the widowed and captain
sanderson
who eventually settled for 700 pounds
equivalent to tens of thousands today
thankfully doves isn't completely lost
swedish designer torbjon olsen created a
digital revival of the font in 1994
attempting to emulate the rounded
corners and imperfections that gave the
printed characters
so much well character
another designer robert green made an
even more polished version of doves
in 2013 and two years later he enlisted
help from the port of london authority
to search the riverbed near hammersmith
bridge
and recover 150 pieces of copden
sanderson's
original type further improving the
accuracy
of his recreation today we're once again
able to enjoy doves
almost exactly as its creator intended
just don't use it to print salacious
letters to your neighborhood's trumpet
or his ghost will doubtless appear to
throw you into the thames as well
the neater style that doves and
countless others followed
was first popularized in the 16th
century
claude garamond made several fonts in
the 16th century
for francis the first king of you'll
never guess
france both the dr soyuz books and the
us editions of harry potter
use garamond whilst the font may look
archaic to us it marked a move away
from heavy intricate gothic letters to
the roman alphabets we used today
despite the far cleaner lines he
introduced
garamond allowed himself more artistic
expression
with one particular character
the ampersand originally adjoining
of e and t from the latin word
for and at ampersands gradually
took on a life of their own and
garamond's version
is a calligraphic masterpiece with its
elegant
curves and tapering lines although
it must have been a to cut out of
metal the ampersand itself
isn't merely an abbreviation it has
the added benefit of bringing the
conjoined elements
closer together phrases like r b
look far more compact and edgier with
only three characters
it makes its way into business names
like a t and t
johnson and johnson and dolce gabbana
offering
an intimacy that the word and cannot
the symbol has such emotive potential
that
in 2010 the society of typographic
aficionados
released coming together a 20
purchasable font consisting entirely
of over 400 different ampersands drawn
by designers
from across the world to raise money for
the victims of the haiti earthquake
the huge emotive potential of fonts
however
can be used less altruistically to
influence our minds when barack obama
ran for the u.s presidency in 2008
his team chose the modern sleek and
streamlined font
gotham developed in 2000 by tobias freda
jones for
gq magazine it took inspiration from
signs around new york city
particularly the 3d lettering that
adorned the city's
port authority bus terminal freda jones
seeing
that many of these physical signs were
being replaced by digital ones
and took it upon himself to photograph
3600 signs across the city
and these became his muses
the simple solid fonts that emerged was
a perfect fit for obama's campaign
ostensibly based on change and
truth with a touch of sophistication
picture the
yes we can slogan but it's likely in
robust gotham it certainly went down
better than his democratic party rival
hillary clinton's choice
with her new baskerville bold intended
to lend
a stately legal quality to her name
but instead publicly squipped as
something that
might have come off a heart-healthy
cereal box
or a mildly embarrassing ointment
perhaps hillary could have used some
advice from psychologist
eric sigmund in 2001 printer company
lexmark commissioned sigmund to look
into what
font choices revealed about their users
it was perhaps unsurprising that soft
curvy fonts like
shelley were generally favored by women
though
lexmark's decision to brand anyone using
these fonts
are sex kitten yes really
was pretty bold lexmark also proclaimed
courier was the font of nerds apparently
favored by librarians
and data entry companies given being a
faux nerd is far cooler now than it was
19 years ago
perhaps it will soon be repurposed by
the hipster hordes
sans serif fonts were chosen by those
that valued their anonymity
and safety and of course the study had
to mention
comic sans with lexmark merely branding
anyone that used it
an attention seeker better that than the
verdict from comic book artist
dave gibbons whose work had initially
inspired it
who called it a real mess and
a particularly ugly letter form
but why is comic sans so
hated it was invented for microsoft's
user-friendly home software package bob
bob included a word processor and a
finance manager
as well as a cute talking dog who
assisted users
but it also gave its instructions in
times new roman
a hugely influential font commissioned
in 1931
to make the times newspaper easier to
read
but times new roman was a little too
formal
for bob comic sans was so named because
it was inspired by
comics its creator vincent connor read
batman
and watchmen comics and created comic
sans to be
intentionally childlike with a
hand-drawn feel
as if its rounded letters had been
carefully written
one by one in the panels of a comic
strip sans
from the french without is from the
phrase
sans-serif a font without serifs
which are the finishing strokes at the
feet and tips of letters
which give type a more traditional feel
in the end comic sans wasn't used in bob
which may be why you've never heard of
the software
it flopped instead it found its way into
microsoft 3d movie maker released in
which allowed children to create choppy
and goofy films
with the help of a frankly terrifying
purple assistant
called mcsee despite mixie's horrific
appearance
and the program's surplus of controls it
was a huge success
and still has a dedicated fan base today
it was also responsible for unleashing
comic sans on the world
the font's inclusion in windows 95
further increased its reach
now people not only saw it but
used it its carefree appearance seemed
perfect for
home printed birthday cards restaurant
menus and student essays
but then it got out of hand it found its
way onto ambulances
textbooks even the playing kit of the
portuguese national basketball team
two graphic designers dave and holly
combs
started the ban comic sans movement
in 1999 they created their website after
being asked by an employer
to use comic sans for a children's
museum exhibit
the pair claimed to have seen the fun to
dawn horrendously unsuited places
such as a gravestone and a doctor's
leaflet on irritable bowel syndrome
because when you've got
ibs the very first thing you need is to
be further
irritated by seeing comic suns
but comic sans isn't the monster some
people make it out to be
it's highly acclaimed for its use with
dyslexics
thanks to its simple clear letters and
it has featured in some
well-loved places like the credits of
sesame street in the early 21st century
or at disney theme parks still
the big problem with comic sans is
undoubtedly its use
in all the wrong places so
in the full report that lexmark had
commissioned
sigmund went on to detail the most
suitable fonts for certain situations
romance for instance calls for fonts
with
big round o's which mimic human faces
and come across as more friendly but if
choosing a human-like font gets you
into a relationship what about getting
out of one
well here you want something clear
without being harsh perhaps an old
faithful like
times regular lighter more optimistic
options which still feel respectful
could be vedana
but if you need a firmer more final end
however
then a more impersonal courier might be
the best choice
more formal circumstances require
similar considerations
with a verdana a fine choice for a
resignation letter from a job you'd
enjoyed
it might not have been popular for ikea
but it's a simple
professional choice although personally
i'm not a fan these days there are much
prettier options
like google's roboto and monserrat but
if you're wanting to part ways more
acrimoniously
sigmund recommends giving them the
typographic equivalent
of the middle finger ariel
ubiquitous and yet unloved ariel is
despised by those in the know
whatever the opposite of a cult classic
is ariel fits the bill
it was designed in the 1980s as a ripoff
of
sorry alternative to helvetica
with which its leading and kerning
spacing
made it perfectly interchangeable any
document written in helvetica could be
changed to aerial
and keep exactly the same layout and
size
add in the fact that ariel's creators
then undercut helvetica's pricing
and you suddenly had ariel as standard
on every windows computer
the vast majority of people don't care
and millions use aerial every single day
but if you know you know and
you use that knowledge to subtly tell
that former boss of yours
where he can shove his terrible job by
giving him
the aerial treatment so maybe ariel has
its place too
after all what better use is there for a
font
than a passive aggressive email thanks
for watching
if you're into fonts and you'll love the
ones in my book sticker flag in it which
you can now buy on amazon
you'll find the link for that in the
description thank you